okay so
we are going to meet now more expressive
uh acceptance conditions robin street
and parity before we do that
let's see where we stand in terms of
expressive power so this is the the
picture
of the word we have so far so
here we have all the languages
of infinite words we know that inside
them
we have the omega regular languages this
is recognized
by nbw so this is these are all the
omega regular languages
inside we have these recognized by
deterministic book your automata it's a
strict subset
we also have deterministic bookie
word automata which complement them and
this is the picture i mean for for
example
here we saw yes
a language that is in a
dbw and not in dcw so let's do it
there so that the blue language here is
for example infinitely many
zeros i always write infinitely many
zeros right they can also
be formal and right in omega regular
expression we didn't
define them but there are only the
regular expression the
complementary one here of
not infinitely many zeros so now if i
write in omega regular language
in another regular expression i want to
see an infinite tale
of ones there are also languages
in the intersection yeah i can write
all all languages of words starting with
zero this is easy
and it can be recognized both by a
deterministic
bookie and the deterministic couple
keyword automaton
and book and kobuki together do not
cover everything so
what i can write for example here so the
usual thing to do and we have two two
subsets i can take something
i can write the infinity mini zero and
not infinitely many ones but to be on
the safe side let's take
the alphabet to be 0 1 and 2. so this is
a language i cannot recognize
by neither a deterministic bookie nor a
deterministic kobuki or automaton
and now the conditions we will meet now
will be such that the deterministic
variant so deterministic gamma
a word automata for gamma being grabbing
straight or party
will be able to recognize all omega
regular languages it will be as
expressive
as non-deterministic bokeh automata
which also means that
there will be a determinization
construction i will be able to
take a non-deterministic booking world
automaton
and translate it to a deterministic
rubbing script or parity
automaton so this is our plan and let's
meet this construct these conditions uh
let's start with robin
a rabin condition so alpha
is now going to be a set of pairs each
pair
has a left set and a right
set so l1 r1 l2
r2 up to lk
rk this k is often
referred to as the index
of the acceptance condition how many
pairs i have
and the index of firefight will also
play a role in
all kinds of complexity analysis
and these i l i and r i they are
subsets of q yes so if you want
a to be cryptic you can say that the
alpha is a member of
2 to the 2 to the q times 2 to the q but
we don't want to be cryptic so
this is our formalism and when
is iran accepting so r
is accepting
if intuitively there is a pair such that
i visit l i infinitely often and visit
ri
only finitely often so if and only
if there exists
i between one to k a pair
such that in for r its intersection
with l i is not empty so i visit
the l guys infinitely often but
if our its intersection with ri
is empty i visit our the bad ones
only finitely often so this is
acceptance by robin
let's see an example and we can take our
usual structure say so whenever i see
a one i go to s1
whenever i see zero i go to s0
and let's say that this is accepting and
suppose i want on top of this structure
to define an automaton for all words
with infinitely many ones
then what i will say i will have a
single pair
i want to visit s1 infinitely often
and i don't care about not visiting
states
so this condition alpha 1
will give me the language of all words
with infinitely many ones right because
iran is accepting if and only if there
is a pair
here we have a single pill such that i
visit
the left set s1
infinitely often and the rights only
finally even
right if the the thing that is written
here yes so we have infinitely many
visits in
li and not infinitely many visits in ri
and in fact you can see i hope already
from this example
that for every bookie if i have a bookie
condition
alpha and i want to translate it to
robin
i will need a single pair they will say
that i want to visit alpha infinity
often and don't care
empty set i mean this is going to be
satisfied vocally
in fulfill the intersection with empty
set is going to be
empty so this is one thing i can do with
this structure
what if i want only finitely many ones i
want to visit
s1 only finitely often so i will define
a beam condition that makes sure i visit
s1 only finitely over i don't want to
restrict
the left side so i will say
that my if its intersection with s0
s1 is not empty but its intersection
with s1
is to be empty and it's not hard to see
that
states that uh both in
l and r are redundant i can remove them
from from where
from l right because i'm not going
uh to see s1 infinitely often anyway i
have this
condition so if i define alpha 2 like
that
it means that i want to see s1 only
finally often
and then the language will be only
finitely many ones
okay so this is in fact how i can do
any crowbookie condition
alpha how i will say it in robin i want
to visit alpha only
finitely often so i will say that
there is a pair a single pair such that
i visit all states
infinitely often so this is going to be
satisfied
always but i visit alpha only infinitely
often
and what we did here erasing this one is
like saying that okay here i don't
really need
whole cube it can be q minus alpha
this is equivalent okay so rabin
is at least as strong as buki and
kobuki stronger because we already have
an example
uh of languages that can be recognized
by arabin and cannot be recognized for
if you came for boogie
so this is a rabin and
the second condition we will see
dualizers
rubbing so it looks the same it is
called street
street condition
and street is dual to robin
the same way kobuki dualizes booking
street a dual
nice login so it looks the same alpha is
still
a set of pairs so l1
r1 f2 lk
okay but now what happens when we
dualize exists there we will say that
for also
r is accepting it satisfies the
condition
if and only if now it will be for
all pairs between 12k
either i visit anyone only finally often
or i visit
r1 infinitely often so
in of our
its intersection with ni is
empty or info from its intersection with
ri
is not empty i'm not sure i wrote end
here here there was an
end yes so we do like this it was exist
i
suck that infinitely many li and only
finally many
yeah alright so now i need for all i
uh only finitely many and i or
infinitely many are i so i can write it
like that so it's a
not infinitely a li
or infinitely now i alternatively i can
say that
infinitely many li imply
infinitely many other so it's exactly
the dual
to robin and if we take our
example let's use the technology here
i can copy
this automaton and now we will reason
about it
as a street automaton so with the street
automaton
if i want to define infinitely many
ones yes i want to visit f1 infinity
often
i will have a single pair how to say
with street
that i want to visit s one infinitely
often i will say that if i visit all
states infinitely often
which happens for sure then i want to
also visit s1 infinitely often
so this is how i will get an automaton
for infinitely many ones and in general
if i have bookie
alpha and want to say it in street i
will need
a single pair that says if you visit q
infinitely often
then visit alpha only finally often
dualizing this if i have a kobuki
condition i want to see alpha only
finitely often
so what will i say you say that if you
visit alpha
infinitely often then you are in trouble
because then
you have to visit also the empty set
infinitely often
but this wouldn't happen so uh
this is how street is stronger
than a bookie and kokoki
and you are welcome to stay on it and
see also how
these conditions we got here dualize the
conditions we got when we translated
buki and kobuki
to rabbi so we have rabin
condition and strict condition
and the third condition perhaps before
we continue
let's just say that on this structure if
i
use the straight condition and i want to
say
infinitely many zero and infinitely many
ones i can do it too
i can do it with two pairs i will say
right because now in straight the
requirement
is a conjunction on all tails for all
pairs i need to satisfy the condition
so i will ask the first pair will make
sure that i am visiting
s0 infinitely often
and the second pair will make sure that
i'm visiting
s1 infinitely often so here you can
see that the general i hope you can see
that we have a general translation of
generalized bookie
to street so if we have here notebooky
but generalized bookie with alpha one
up to alpha k then in the street
i will have k pairs
each of them taking care of a
single seat so these were
robin in street now let's talk about the
parity condition
so parity looks a bit different party
colors the states of the automaton
so it marks each state to we call them
colors
from zero to k so we actually have k
plus one
colors and what about uh
defining when run is accepting so
right we have colors to the states and
we have an infinite run the infinite and
traversal states it is going to visit
some of the colors
infinitely often and some of the colors
uh only finitely open and the
definition of acceptance we will say
that r is accepting
if the minimum color that it
visits infinitely often is even
so if and only if so we will first write
the intuition then
formalize if we formalize it so
if and only is so that the intuition
is the minimal color
that are
visits infinitely often
is even formally
we are going to say that the minimum
of the set so here i have all the colors
i such that in
its intersection with alpha in minus one
of
i is not empty
so what is this set this is the set of
colors that were visited
infinitely often so i want this minimum
to be even and
before we continue and digest a
this definition a in the literature you
will see all kinds of
variants you may see a
definitions that refer to the max you
may see definitions atmosphere
that want it to be odd you may see
definitions that start with one
and not with zero so it's already eight
variants
there are all very similar in the
properties we will walk
with the minimal color being even
and in order to digest it let's
before we see an example let's see that
parity is really a special case
uh of a of robin
and street so suppose i have a parity
condition
alpha and sometimes it is convenient to
describe
alpha is the set of a
states that are colored by each color
yes
so alpha i is alpha i mean
minus 1 of i yes so this is
alpha i all states that are colored
by a certain color so suppose i have
such an alpha condition let's see that i
can
describe parity in the special case of
robin
why if i want the minimum to be
even then it means i can define a
condition alpha prime
wrapping that will be equivalent to this
alpha what will i say
i want the minimal color to be even
so i want for example
a to visit alpha zero
infinitely often and then i'm done right
if i'm visiting alpha zero infinity
often then i satisfy the parity
condition
because the minimal color that is
visited infinitely often
is even is zero what if i
visit a alpha 2 infinitely often i need
to visit
alpha one or infinitely often and in
order to make it
minimal i will also add alpha 0
i can also visit alpha 4 infinitely
often
and accept if i visit alpha 3
union alpha 2 union alpha 1 union alpha
0
infinitely often you can see i can take
out the
even this is here but i'm leaving them
for completeness
so i can continue like that yeah so i
can it depends whether k
is even or odd but you can see the idea
of writing parity is robin
i can also write parity in street
now it is street how
i want the minimum to be even so
what does it mean it mean that if i
visit
alpha one infinitely often this is not
good
unless i visit a alpha zero
infinitely often yes this one says if
alpha one is visited infinitely often
i don't want one to be the minimal index
so i will visit
a alpha zero infinitely often and if i
visit
alpha 3 infinitely often i don't want it
to be the minimal
then i have to visit infinitely often
also
alpha 0 or alpha 1 or alpha 2
and we continue like that so this is
parity as a special case of a
rubbing street the other direction
doesn't work if i have a rubbing
condition i cannot
translate it as if yeah
we will see that we can play with the
structure of the automaton
but just a translation of the acceptance
condition of being a special case of
this wouldn't work the last thing we
want to say about
a authority is to say that it is
stronger than booking kobuki
yeah how can i say bookie as
parity yes if i want to visit alpha
infinitely often so i have bookie
alpha how will i translate it
to parity so this is the key
i want to give it infinitely often okay
so i will say
that a well if the minimal
is i started they said that they started
with zero so i will say
just a alpha
gets a color zero and q minus alpha
gets color one and this would work right
because
if i visit alpha infinity often the
minimal column
that is going to be visited infinitely
often uh
is zero what about kobuki
if i have a kobuki condition alpha
i want to visit it only finitely often
so i want to what
wait i will leave it as an exercise
a and this will be a the other
a bookie and kobuki is parity
uh now that we have these three
conditions
there are three issues uh we want to to
mention
and each of these issue is a heavy topic
we can talk about for a several lectures
we will just survey them so the one is
the issue of expressive power
and succinctness
which is a we want
to get convinced that indeed
we got a automata that are not stronger
than bouquet
but i can translate robin street and
party
to booking but i do gain something
i i gain success the automata i need in
order to define languages
are smaller so this is one issue
the second issue is how much does it
cost
to be more succinct and this is the
complexity
a of decision problems
for example of deciding whether the
language of the
automaton is empty so this is something
that requires a different procedure for
each of the different
acceptance conditions and we want to see
the different complexities
and the third thing is determinization
determinization
and a complementation too
yes how to go for example from a
non-deterministic booking word automaton
to a deterministic
rabbin word automaton which will
complete the picture yes which will show
us that the picture we do
here we can indeed put a robin and
straight and parity bill so these are uh
three heavy topics and in in the next
lecture
we will say some things about each of
them